donc on a vu d'autres je suis retraité
du groupe général à compter du 1er
janvier 2016 alors j'ai été envahie et
on entendait tantôt dont plus de 20 ans
au conseil général dans les transports
juste après bien décentralisation c'est
à dire à l'époque 82 86 1 les suis
arrivée au conseil général leur pain
dans les services de transport de veolia
était dans le privé d'enlever aux gars
et on avait créé un cv des transports
quand les dompter
on avait passé un marché pour avec le
conseil général donc on organiser les
transports scolaires au prix pas le
département donc il fallait faire une
étude tous à pouvoir ramasser tous les
données les élèves
où est ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire les
points d'arrêt ans et après west qui
vont aider dans les écoles les écoles à
que le uk life et organiser tout ça et
ont organisé en ce temps-là on dans les
chiottes du papier millimétré mais pas
limité au bout de 2h 3h en concert à
travailler sur un papier millimétré
on ne distinguait distinguer plus si ce
qui est mm de mm puis sera donc j'avais
et comme j'aimais quand on le
le goût pour les
l'informatique j'ai travaillé sur une
application excellent et j'ai programmé
les faits la programmation des
transports scolaires sur sl et ça nous a
gagné énormément de temps parce que
c'est faisait les feuilles de service et
calculer les kilomètres calculé sentier
des halles afin d en deux manches et une
faute le conseil général a repris sa
compétence
et comme ils n'avaient pas détecté à
transports ils ont demandé les
techniciens de spots de venir travailler
pas propre on comprend points donc là il
était responsable de service il ya toute
la partie organisationnelle et avant ça
je faisais j'ai fait
caron dans les collectes des ordures
ménagères étaient même pions dans encore
au rectorat quoi voilà roger fait de
licence une licence de mathématiques
élisant de mécanique
non on n'a rien à voir mais disons la
licence heures ou quand même l'esprit
roger surtout dans le domaine par
exemple l'informatique ça permet de
de réfléchir d'être logique des compos
de travailler il faut aimer aussi quoi
voilà les des rues quand même pas mal
d'applications pour les transports
scolaires des handicapés pour le compte
du conseil général et j'ai des enfants
des enfants métropole il ya un marché
qui est professeur l'analyse et au
niveau au niveau marne-la-vallée ajouté
ensuite après j'ai mon fils qui est dans
l'affirmative
donc j'ai aux camions tous les ans
d'aller faire un petit tour
même alors à la retraite avant de songer
investi dans dans un bateau un bon je
vais à la pêche deux fois par semaine
après je bricole un peu et puis j'ai
occupé de mes plantes et puis j'ai
l'occasion des fois dû donner quelques
cours de mathématiques à près de deux
secondes
et parfois ces six concours sur
l'apparition fera demain voilà c'est
tout un avant tout c'est les loisirs il
fait beaucoup de pétanque aussi donc le
forage
il évolue sion transports qui a au
niveau de la région
c'est ce roi le train de l'est quand il
existera toujours
parce que le train il pourra pas le tram
ou étrangers patel suarez ne pourra pas
desservir les eaux il pourra pas faire
le tour de l'île
ok donc il ya toujours besoin des cas et
donc soit plutôt un complément il va
ramener il à rabat les écoles et les
personnes sur le tram et ensuite après y
croit ainsi avis beaucoup plus forte et
beaucoup d endroits - surtout -
d'embouteillage quoi voilà